welcome to this video second-round
action for the candidates in countyman
disc and the game I'm going to look at
in this video is aronian against
Mammadyarov aronian would the terrible
start losing the first game first round
with black against Anand and it really
wasn't a good game I mean it rarely
happens that you can be satisfied with a
loss but I guess he was some yeah he had
simply had an off day and wasn't wasn't
really a yea in this game so I wrong
young and really desperate need to get a
win in this tournament not like
desperate maybe a too strong word but he
is certainly in some kind of zoosk 12 to
show something mayara had to draw in the
first round so he um can be a quite
satisfied with the start I guess he had
some chances against to pawn off maybe
but still not a bad start so let's see
what happened in the game aronian going
for deform his main opening move and
videographers some russet our player but
here he goes for the Rogozin defense in
the Queens gambit um yeah he has played
that before but also Aronian is an
expert on that line with both colors so
they both should know quite some things
about this the Rogozin is one of the
more active defenses in the Queens
gambit compared to the classical
variation with Bishop e7 the flavor of
this line the rosin is much more like
the nympho Indian in many lines it sort
of combines the Queens gambit and the
NIMS oh of course black is committed to
an early d5 p.m. it's the Queens gambit
after all so transpositions to the NIMS
o are somewhat limited to lines for
black has played d5 obviously
we can have direct transpositions in
some cases if Aronian here for example
would go III let's say castles Bishop d3
c5 and when an absolute main line
Rubenstein an Enzo it's possible but ok
the main move here is Bishop g5 besides
taking which can easily transpose but he
played Bishop g5 a.m. and we would you
are up late night bd7 here black can
also play other moves you can play a
huge six interesting alternative or you
can play the capture which is a very
very sharp but 97's and nowadays
probably the most popular move ya know
Aronian exchanged on d5 and plate 92
this is an interesting idea um I know
that aronian has played this before I
found her examples for that but I never
really um considered this line and had
to had a study of it but now that I
looked at this game and it feels like an
interesting way for white to play um a
positive feature of this line is
obviously that the night on d2 helps to
break this pin on the night 0 on XIII
and this means that white now actually
threatens to just take d 5 black cannot
play a move like let's say castles and
ignore everything because white oops
we'll just take on d5 and it winds upon
for absolutely nothing so black needs to
react to the threat on d5 this also
applies in case of the movie 5 which
otherwise would be black sir normal next
move like let's say III black you'll
place in five and here after 92 this is
simply not possible as again 95 is on so
black basically has to do something
about this simple threat and there are
two moves Bishop e7 moving it again not
terrible I mean
the bishop on before is maybe after
having provoked 92 not so excellently
placed on before so this should be seven
is not in not bad I can play as
Mammadyarov did c6 this is actually
related as the bishop quite often
returns anyway but I think he wants to
keep his options open maybe put it just
on d6 if the circumstances are right for
that so c6 covering on d5 III and night
f8 what we now have is somewhat strange
yeah let's say it's a typical um pawn
structure for the Queens gambit
exchanges oftentimes called card spot
structure which means that C and D porn
have been exchanged and white has this
typical point Center d4 III against d5
c6 those pawns this is typically called
the card spot structure from this famous
city where lots of tournaments have been
played um and in case we I think we are
speaking about tournaments in the 1920s
and somewhat somewhat earlier of the
20th century yeah the weird thing is we
have to snip a good bone structure but
the piece placement is somewhat
different the bishop is on before and
said o v7 and the night is on d 2 so
this if for instance this doesn't make
much sense but just to to show what I'm
talking about if white would now drop
this back and black would drop this back
we would have a completely normal
position in them the Queens gambit
exchange of course wide it's not moving
the night again but it's just this
structure with a twist 9 f8 is
interesting it quickly intends to
regroup the night free of this bishop
for potential development and also allow
two things the night might go here and
then play age six to win the bishop pair
will see that in the game
this idea or the other ideas Blackie can
also go here this is some also classical
regrouping in the structure 96 and then
G 697 Bishop f5 this is typically
associated with them another player from
that era of the 1920s and 30s it's a
star back to to pronounce it with the
German flavor flavor style back i think
he was I think it was swedish i'm not
mistaken no ok um this is another plan
but ok Bishop d3 was played to prevent
Bishop f5 yeah and black went with the
night to g6 the mentioned plan is like
that this was also a possibility 96
bishop age four and then g6 for instance
let's say something like that it's what
black can try to do go here and then
Bishop f5 this is the the plan that that
I described the general idea at least
I'm not sure that you can execute it and
in this particular way but this is the
general idea for example if you look at
this here castles 97 what I think as
this is funny shot quite nice because of
this opinion after CD there's a 4 check
yeah ok but he went 96 anyway which opts
for another plan yeah f for this is very
ambitious white probably intends to put
the night back to f3 and to e5 this erm
makes some sense out of the 90 to move
from in this particular structure and it
might intend to play f5 gaining even
more space and we quickly get to a very
concrete position and the dr of plays h6
and we had this caption f6 white has no
place anywhere for the bishop yeah and
he aronian played the move f5 and now
let's have a look at the clocks we are
on one hour 43 I believe in this case
the clock times are quite near what
actually was happening in the game we
always there's always a slight the
slight delay its not 100% precise but to
be close to that a team of adyar of
played to move 97 after four minutes
thought and in fact this position is
already highly critical because black
cow must consider what to do now with
the night it's obviously critical you
have many squares you have h eight which
looks entirely ridiculous you have h
form which also looks a bit strange
because consider this move where is the
night exactly going it does not really
have a square if why it goes Queen h5
you are facing this threat and what
should like do we probably get a
position like that Bishop takes rook
takes yeah note that take with the
bishop there's the funny move g6 which
is perfectly okay for black where you be
at tactic linked by drug at five night
and five Queen f5 Queen fi Bishop f5 and
this is an interesting position to
consider it arises almost by force after
this night H formals look at this
position right it's got two pieces two
nights actually against rook and pawn
and the computer this case Houdini for
this s is the position has completely
equal but this surprised me i mean i
think that most human players would
definitely prefer to be YTM by some
extent or another not sure how much but
if you just give people a choice
would you rather be in this position I
think they mostly would take right
because it feels like it's relatively
close black has seven points seven
points but these are what's or seven
points that can be attacked by by the
minor pieces while the rooks are not so
we have not not actually roaming on the
board it's um I think position that
initially black would rather not play
okay you do it if you don't have a great
choice if the alternatives are clearly
worse but it's not terribly attractive
and yeah what other movers there yeah
black in fact has an interesting
tactical move he has the move Queen to
g5 and it turns out that this would have
been robbed okay for black Queen g5
what's the idea of course if why it
takes to grep here and get your bishop
back with the black enjoying a pawn and
an excellent position so this is not on
white needs to protect the pawn and this
is possible with the various Queen moves
um in fact you could analyze this much
deeper but i just given given a sample
line right place Queen f3 then night
edge for actually wins the temple and
then maybe Queen g3 and here for
instance it's not not mandatory move
like Bishop e7 it's not doing much on
before anyway and he had lent support to
the night and this is an entirely
unclear position I'm really not sure how
to assess it um yeah let's say rook gave
a one its many moves possible and black
now can play even g6 attacking this this
square this pawn and this seems
perfectly acceptable for black despite
this somewhat strange looking night it's
a it's probably about equal white can
also play Adams with the Queen to to
cover Queenie to for example then also
night h4 is coming in now yeah like
Assam
attacking this three times and white
needs to react somehow and not sure what
what you should do I'm a move like
neither 3m yeah black gets rid of this
somewhat yeah offside night this
liability is now taken away and black
should be perfectly okay so black
actually had a good alternative here 297
which looks perfectly natural I admit
and this is what number dr off plate
knight to e7 alright so now in this
video I'll give you a few small puzzle
to solve exactly this position I know it
looks entirely harmless like right out
of an opening book we on move 14 now for
white but if you want treat it as a
puzzle I'll be silent for a couple of
seconds so that you can easily pause the
video and then look for yourself is
really like that white to play and win
yeah amazingly enough white actually now
can yeah I guess win the game almost
it's a it's fair to say i mean it's it's
not completely completely trivial but
very close white wins the game with the
move that huronian plate after 10
minutes of thought my D to e for quite
amazingly this night jumps to you form
where it can be taken so what's the idea
black takes it and it took sleet took it
quickly now by now had realized probably
what you are done night x and now we see
the the big problem look at the Queen
cannot go to e7 these this squares are
also guarded by white white pieces so
there only is one square left Queen to
edge form yeah and now aronia play 2 g-3
it's very sorry very important to not
play look at four here which was my
initial thought okay well trap the Queen
that's nice
but black actually can continue the game
he can take on a form and play night at
five I mean the other the game continues
you can also continue but this feels
much more difficult in comparison to the
game because this is simply a week for
white if you look at the game you played
g3 attacking the Queen it only has one
square on age three and then night f2
was played and now the queen is strapped
it has no square and it needs to yeah
get as much material as possible so she
takes on everyone just taking the rook
and wide we captured and if you compare
this to the other position where white
had this yeah we can also play this move
out in the other position wyd actually
had pawn on f4 and an isolated pawn on
d4 and he has perfectly healthy pawn
structure in the center it's not
perfectly healthy as a bit much because
III is somewhat weak but that's not a
serious issue yeah so what do we have
here what's got six pounds black has got
six points pawn count is equal but white
as the Queen for Bishop and rook and as
they are no particular features that
favor black on white should should win
the game in addition he also has a look
at the next move you can play that on
the board we see that white actually has
some his forces in play the rook here is
the only piece that is not playing
quickly but it can join the action on
some central square e 1 okay need to be
careful but the rook is ready to join
what black is still on the back ranks
and white has a center in fact so black
is not dominating with pieces in the
center to compensate yeah basically now
the game enters some can almost
technique
task and after 96 Abronia takes the
center and now step-by-step manages to
improve all pieces and this is the the
right strategy here not allow anything
specific by black don't expose your own
King for example as wide and just try to
slowly advance and I think he's playing
this nicely night on d3 to improve it
maybe on c5 later on f4 king of one was
necessary there was an ID f2 threatened
so he steps out of any inconveniences
and here the night arrives on a form
yeah and it's not so easy for black not
to take it um yeah what what else is
there if you don't take it let's say you
return this even though this movie 5
what's the point if black takes wiser
enters with a direct win on h7 yeah it's
very very ugly black must a Content ID
itself and now black we captured white
we captured with the pawn yeah this
completes a great center for white and
it also um is the foundation for whites
next mini plan you play this position
with the little plants that actually
accumulate the advantages to improve the
position further and further and this
spawn mass in the center now is the base
form advancing the pawn cm23 to cover
deform slowly improving and now after
some further expansion on the queenside
white pushes in the center with a 5 it
didn't even need to to include the rook
in the game it's not necessary at the
pond just advance forward and yeah black
is trying to hold on but it's not it's
not really possible to defend note that
Aronian is taking time he's not blitzing
this this is very important he he's
completely aware that he needs to win
this now and of course it's a winning
position but if for whatever reason he
is not winning this the tournament for
him is basically over I mean
psychologically this would be
devastating so it's you should really
make sure to absolutely kill off or
counter play and win this clearly and
okay he's got a couple of minutes left
there's no reason to to rush things
White has everything under control yeah
throw the advancing now he lets rook
enter the game on the G file that's very
nice and logical on age 6 the porn is
hanging so black reacts and here this
position move 37 um yeah here Aronian
could have won the game even quicker
than he did um I'm spoiling this right
but it's not not a big spoiler you
probably expect him to win now um he
could have won some work quicker with
the cheese sacrifice on g7 here takes
and queen h5 and it turns out that this
threat is so enormously strong that
black has no defense against the
upcoming attack for example if we if we
look at this let's say rook to evade to
cover a bit check check give a couple of
checks if you want and at the end you
take and play a seven you could say that
okay this looks rather cooperative to
put that put the rukon f8 in this in
this fork but what exactly should black
play it's a
it's really a tricky with you can look
at this for example check this is a
magic mate Joe this is also made so
Rooke g7 was winning but it's not really
necessary he's got 12 minutes on the
clock he probably calculated some lines
and then decided ok I've got to make
three more moves or formal moves to to
get to the time control and yeah I'm
winning this technically so why do
anything like that he just improved the
pieces a bit further Queen a3 covering
important squares and having e7 in mind
so like capture and his heaven at some
stage Bishop c4 rook g4 he just wants to
make the time control and limit every
every counter play imaginable two to
nothing yeah like just waits and he just
wants to make move 40 very pragmatic
decision and now that move for t is is
reached he gets a couple of extra
minutes like one hour sorry not a couple
one hour you see that the clock is
jumping up again and now we see some
precise moves to to finish black off
night when air force was tried rook to
d1 and king edge 8 yeah and now why this
finishing things off with the nice move
d5 that some the game that that's the
move that decides because after the
capture here why just the text the night
yeah send ya 2 h 3 which is kind of
funny now here and now bishop h5 and the
e pawn and the h4 threat this is just
too much let something like that for
example here the rook has absolutely no
square for example
yeah like it's uh it's just completely
busted if he takes with the night I
think they did that right yes in the
game we took with the night and then
around your plate we should h5 this was
one idea to get this square on age 54
the bishop now the rook is attacked and
it has no place to go we can go to GA
them but then d7 just promote the porn
or wins yet another piece so like 97 and
why this even a queen up for ya for a
single rook rook enter yeah couple of
porns which don't really matter here so
a very very important win for a roni on
here um after I'm not sure if I
mentioned that after Bishop a tribe
black resigned very important winter
Aronian who's back in the tournament
after this really a puzzling loss in the
first round he immediately could strike
back and win this this game certainly
with lots of help in the in form of this
blunder of a movie are off but it does
not matter in this case you need to
point and every kind of point is enough
certainly nice to play a good game and
not let's say it be completely lost and
the other guy just blonde as a piece in
Time trouble and then you get the point
but the most important thing is to get
back to fifty percent so he's back into
the race with fifty percent and arguably
it's probably psychologically even very
okay for him now I mean you had this off
day and now when prop maybe shows him
that ok I'm able to to bounce back even
if it was mostly due to a row to
Mammadyarov baquero for Mammadyarov of
course this is really a bad start now I
mean he was one of my I've got to cliff
got to UM dark horses in this tournament
where father came maybe with a good
start they can do something one of them
was familiar
and with this loss now yeah that's it
basically in terms of having a good
start and maybe do something in the
tournament it's important to not them
get into a really bad shape now and play
a good game tomorrow frame after such a
blunder right in the opening basically
giving the Queen away um this um can can
turn out to be very tough tournament as
we learned last year an example of a job
of who really had the rotten form and
finished last and this tournament of
last year London alright thanks for
watching this video I hope you enjoyed
it and I'll be back of course tomorrow
with other with next round and also
there are the other games to check out
for round two they were all interesting
really all of them alright thanks for
watching